يعني محمود درويش قال نحن نحب الحياه اذا
ما استطعنا اليها سبيلا
شعبنا يحب الحياه ولكن لا سبيل
له يعيش هذه الحياه ماذا
احتلال الشاب الفلسطيني للفتى الفلسطيني
من رؤيا
امامه
جدارا
سميكا وغطاء من السمسم اسود حتى لا يستطيع
ان يرى المستقبل من خلاله ماذا افقت
السلطه لهذا الشعب الفلسطيني هذا الشعب
الفلسطيني من رؤيا المستقبل لا شيء ماذا
افعل العرب لهذا الشاب الفلسطيني من رؤيا
المستقبل لا شيء ماذا ابقى المجتمع الدولي
من المستقبل الشعب الفلسطيني وبالتالي
الشعار الذي قراته قراته بالامس على احد
جدران في الدقه الغربيه يقول يعني داء
للشاب الفلسطيني
حذاري ان تموت
موتا طبيعيا
حذاري ان تموت موتا طبيعيا هذه الرساله
التي توجهها الى الشعب الفلسطيني بمعنى مت
شهيدا
اين هو مستقبل وما هو مستقبل هذا الفتى
اللي عمره 13 سنه لا مستقبل له لا شيء
وبالتالي هو الذي يختار مستقبله بنفسه الا
يموت موتا طبيعيا ان يموت شهيدا هذه
الحاله الفلسطينيه
ليس فقط ان العالم لا يفهمها وانما لا
يريد ان يفهمها لانه لا يرى الفلسطيني
انسانا ماذا كانت تصريح
بايدين بالامس انه هذه العمليات ضد
الحضاره
وكانه يعني ما في حضاره عربيه احنا وحوش
وفي حضاره اسرائيليه نحن ضد هذه الحضر هاي
الوحوش ضد الحضاره هذا التصور يجب ان يلقى
ردا فلسطينيا قريبا بان لا يستقبل وزير
الخارجيه
الامريكي في رام الله
يجب ان لا يستقبل طالما ان هناك موقف
امريكي معادل الشعب الفلسطيني ويعتبر
الشعب الفلسطيني وحوش